er lädt gta4 roman belek altersklassen
nico bettge sport man muss also
offensichtlich
heiko tadge bekommen zum ladies and
gentlemen und bonding zum nächsten teil
von houstons sammelt und conne 3
wir haben wir ein super super punkte
system ausgedacht aus den kommentaren
jedenfalls hat die person ins petty
patrick geschrieben was vor drei tagen
ja vor drei tagen das haben wir jetzt
bemerkt weil der zehn milliarden
kommentare angekommen sind ist ist so
jedenfalls hat er geschrieben ihr sollt
die punkte machen dass man drei punkte
bekommt der andere wenn ihr erraten hat
ohne einen tipp zu geben
er bekommt zwei punkte wenn er erwarte
davon einen tipp 1 punkt wenn er erraten
hat wenn man im zweites gegeben hat und
null punkte wenn man es nicht erwarten
hat oder halt viel mehr als die im
endeffekt geht es darum dass selbst
steht ob tipps wenn irgendwie noch
verbesserungen für das punktesystem habt
dann könnt uns in den comments schreiben
experte patrick zum beispiel nicht
gekommen
wir machen jetzt erstmal diese folge so
da guck mal wie das ankommt und dann
gucken wir mal ob das nächste folge
nicht für mich mal wieder anders nicht
genau weil ein bisschen gucken wir sagen
hat um am ende halt ja zum beispiel wäre
dieser folgende schwerpunkte hat
gewonnen und bei der nächsten folgen
vielleicht andere punktesystem mit
sondern komme jeden fall würde ich sagen
soll ich anfangen
ich muss sagen 20 spiel aber natürlich
über chancen gehabt
natürlich haben uns nicht belohnt dafür
was lukas podolski
[ __ ] ja drei punkte wären die chancen
ohne würfel
die welt werde ich als tipp gebracht
lukas podolski muss
ok guten tag ich bin ein großartiger
schauspieler spielen verschiedenen
filmen mit weg und ich muss sagen ich
meine ich habe eine kleine tochter und
habe eine ganze scheiße chemiker drei
punkte
ihr müsst jetzt viele schwierige routen
aufgemacht ja aber schon gute nacht
der trainer kennt
wie bist du bereit für die nächste
person
ich bin richtig wollen wir nach den
kunden gehen wann es erregt weil das
echt mega einfach alter halt dich bist
du einfach aufgebot
jeder bestimmt nicht irgendein youtube
ich dachte da kenne ich mich gar nicht
mit
dieses neuland so bestand die drei
punkte muss ich erst mal drauf zählen
ok luca dass unser mann bekennt oder
pass auf jetzt muss ruhe sein opfer dann
kann ich mit käse kessel öffentliche
koreaner denkst klasse ich kann auf
einem moped an
ich weiß aber ich will dass meine decke
noch den kleidern ist
ich sage zu dem alto missgeburt auf dem
balkon oder was das für waschmaschinen
indem sie wieder gehen weil krieg
menschen nicht verboten ist
wir können uns ja auch leute in die
kommentare schreiben
das ganz wichtig schreibt uns schwierig
die imitation in die kommunikation
schwierig auf jeden fall jetzt nicht
natürlich eure nachbarn
das kann natürlich nicht erraten
das ist der nachbar von dem
kommentarschreiber da hab ich den müll
daraus entstehen lassen
ok ich finde ja jugend dass man zum
beispiel kommen
was bist du verloren so nah ich weiß
nicht das ohr hast du schon gesagt hat
jetzt nicht so gut rumschreien alter es
ist ein spät abends auch noch ein leder
rechts aber nicht so schnell okay so
meine freunde mehr traktion und lecker
lassen hallo zusammen ich bin sehr
kulinarischer mensch du weißt nicht
behindert ihn das letzte mal schon
gebracht ich war zwei klassen und keiner
meine freunde bist du behindert den hast
du letztes mal schon gebaut ist mit
horst schlämmer schlämmer liefert ihren
zettel egger glas nutella meine feinde
es ist nicht schlämmer großer runder man
okay er ist okay erster tipp okay
nein ich will auch keinen tipp das ist
nicht schlämmer wird er noch seine
spielen noch man nehme man keinen
anderen
ich glaube ich habe mein tipp okay ich
bin im fußball tätig bayer leverkusen
alter kommt schon luca rudi völler
okay okay rheine
es gab auf 1live gab es eine serie hieß
frittieren mit der firma glas mit einer
meiner freunde ich bin so ein dicker
mann deshalb kaiser calmund nachbarn
bruder oder das war noch an ihm aber ich
habe zwei tipps gegeben wo ist der
weiher ist er bei bayer leverkusen
er war bei bayer leverkusen erwartet wo
ist der jetzt der ist reines fett wie
sonstwas keine anderen land irgendwo
illegal der frist irgendwo bei mir dort
fest scheiß drauf du hast du ein punkt
gegen der war bis 2004 bei leverkusen
ja ist doch egal hast du das google ja
verändert der junge aber er war bei
bayer leverkusen und du hast die mit das
ist eine sache das ist ein fehltritt
alter dass hier ein tipp dann das
empfiehlt das ist nur ein tipp dann ja
dann fick dich halt christa zwei punkte
ja diese youtube werbung mit ihm doch
fluege de da würde ich gerne
februar nein ich hab ein glas mit team
umgeworfen
eine paprika drauf
aber du bist dran
wer hat das gesagt
ja aber wann
als er tom rüdell war weil er hat es nur
in einer szene so gesagt irgendwann mal
so ja ich weiß ich weiß
die szene wurde mit sirius black sich im
betrunkenen oder trifft ihn seitlich
küssen
der film heißt glaube ich harry potter
und die kammer des schreckens
wenn ich mich recht entsinne keine
ahnung was du zu mir das ist da kann man
keine tipps geben alter was ist das denn
für ein spiel habe ich jetzt gewonnen
ich würde sagen du bekommst zwei punkte
weil sollte man richtig aber er ich will
attraktiv machen sich könnte jeder sein
aber wacker verweilt der zauberspruch
womit er links umgebracht hat die eltern
von harry und harry halt auch mit oliven
wollte hat der maler kipawa raten von
figuren nicht von irgendwelchen
zeitpunkten irgendwelchen büchern morgen
oder es gibt drei punkte
zweieinhalb ich das denn jetzt mit
buchstaben 2 und 0 5 2 als ok durch luca
warum ist falsch deine mutter okay du
führst punkten
ja ich bin was ich bin sagt man das so
frage ich mich verarschen einfach weiter
zitat aus einem sehr sehr berühmten song
wer gerade mega- gehalt wird tyler the
creator bei gott mein alter nur weil ich
ihr das hat gezeigt habe
pizza alter [ __ ] bitte wie kommst du
darauf ich weiß es nicht alter das
geraten
wer ist denn ich bin nie sagt man du
kannst bruder war das jetzt zwei punkte
oder weil wir immer so der der reviere
der machte was er was dir oder der
digitalen bücher nicht ich würde sagen
es gibt zwei punkte ok ok werde ich
jetzt drei punkte kriege ist gleichstand
da gibt es ein stechen
ok ok games to new york so max manni
musste probleme huras mir zum extremes
network kommentator face der diktator
bist du behindert den tipp haben nein
noch nicht
das ist der diktator viktor bout hat der
kommt er nach new york und er sagt dass
auch ein bungalow meine freunde das ist
mein name borat aber er spricht englisch
luca komm schon
es ist einem ich will keine tipps alter
ich muss drei punkte bekommen
[ __ ] [ __ ] alter
das ist nicht dein ernst sack ist
franklin alter
treffer alt michael nein aber es ist ja
dass gta gelaufen das ist eine aus gta
ausgeht year as rom 1 berlich gta4 roman
beleg altersklassen die combo spaß man
muss doch so offensichtlich
ich würde alles hauptsache ich dem ziel
die charaktere aus gta 5
wer war noch mal wo man hingeht er fiel
tatsächlich spielt gehört wie sein
bruder der russe der nach gta kommt nach
gta kommen
wie alt die krise mit somit gibt es laut
gefahr
er kommt mit der anschluss beim er den
firmanden ein sieg für mich gewesen
das heißt er insgesamt hat er jetzt 1 2
3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 punkte ab
ja dann würde ich sagen muss luca auch
eine kleine strafe machen ehe joker
singt jetzt einfach in der nächsten
folge ein kleines lied wie unglaublich
scheiße dort ist jetzt machen wir nie
das muss schon richtig produziert sein
schneidest du bittest für die nächste
aufnahme okay aber gerät ist nur vor der
nächsten aufnahme wie ich nach dinge
dass ich scheiße sind luca singt wie
scheiße ist mit facetime auch das mache
ich aber erst wenn wir beim ein video
und bei deinem video 2006 geschafft
haben okay weil 2006 luca wie scheiße
ist also merkt euch das alter ist okay
meine freunde da schwarz vom dieser
runde wer ist es
schreibt uns auf jeden fall in die
kommentare wenn wir nach machen sollen
wenn ihr die super gameplays die vor und
zurückgespult werden bei rewe sehen
wollte schreiben
er kommt in den nach einer runde auf der
ersten folge ihr seht ihr oben rechts
ein bild von der brain eingeblendet die
hübschen
eingeblendet hast du ja ehrlich
grafikkarte würde sagte der aufnahme ist
aber wiederum regelsatz ermessen bild
von ihr
welches die hübschen weiterhin leute in
die kommentare schreiben
gefahndet wird unsere ideen sicher nicht
so die allermeisten und dann